غاره اسرائيليه على مطار حلب الدولي ومصدر
سوري واكيد خروج المطار عن الخدمه
البيت الابيض يقولون تصميم طالبات في
ايران يستدعي بعثه امميه لتقصي الحقائق
ويصف الامر بالمخزي
والصين تندد بحمله غربيه لتطويخها وتحضر
واشنطن من تجاوز الخط بشان تايمون
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا بكم معنا
الى هذه النشره المفصله تاتيكم من العربيه
افاد اعلام نظام السوري بشن اسرائيل غاره
على مطار حلب الدولي موضحا ان اسرائيل
نفذت الهجوم الجوي من اتجاه البحر المتوسط
الغربي الذي قيل ما ادى الى حدوث اضرار
ماديه في مطار حلب الدولي وخروجه عن
الخدمه واضافت المصادر النافعه الجويه
السوريه تصدت للصواريخ الاسرائيليه التي
استهدفت محيطه مطاري حلب
طلب البيت الابيض باجراء تحقيق مستقل ذي
مصداقيه وبمعاقبه المسؤولين عن تصميم
الطالبات في ايران مشيرا الى ان هذه
القضيه يمكن ان تكون ضمن صلاحيات بعثه
الامم المتحده الدوليه المستقله لتقصي
الحقائق في ايران في حال ثبت ان عمليه
التصميم هذه على صله بالمشاركه في
الاحتجاجات كما اشار بيان البيت الابيض
الى ان تسميم الفتيات في المدارس
الايرانيه لمجرد مطالبتهن بالتعليم امر
مخزن
[موسيقى]
من جههها اعلنت وزاره الداخليه الايرانيه
ان النتائج الاوليه للتحقيقات في قضيه
التسمم بالمدارس لم تكشف عن وجود اي مواد
سامه او خطيره في الطلاب الذين تم فحصهم
ذكرت الوزاره ان 90% من الشكاوي في قضيه
تسمم كانت ناجمه عن القلق والمخاوف التي
سادت الفصول مؤكده على ان عددا محدودا فقط
من الطلاب شعروا بمضاعفات
[موسيقى]
وبدوره لا تزال روايات نظام الايراني
متضاربه بشان حاله تسمم الطالبات كما تبين
ردود فعله بين انكار وادان وشجب وتهديد
بالعقاب المزيد في هذا التقرير
روايات عده والواقعه واحده 100 طالبات
الايرانيات في المشافي والسبب هجمات
بالمواد الكيماويه هرم السلطه الايرانيه
من جانبه يستنكر ويشجب المرشد الايراني
علي خامني دور للنظام في حوادث تسمم ووصف
تصميم الايرانيات بانه جريمه لا تختفر على
السلطات تتبع قضيه تصميم التلميذات بجديه
هذه جريمه لا تغتفر تجب معاقبه مرتكبي هذه
الجريمه بقسوه الرجل الثاني في ايران
الرئيس الايراني ينكر ويرفض الاعتراف
بوقوع حالات تسمم للطالبات ويصفها بمؤامره
من العدو تسميم الطالبات حلقه اخرى من
العدو لاثاره التوتر والتهويل داخل
المجتمع ونشر الخوف
اما السلطه القضائيه في ايران فقد اكتفت
بالتعهد بتطبيق عقوبه الاعدام على
المتسببين في تسميم الطالبات كانت الحكومه
اعلنت فتح تحقيق في اسباب التسمم الا انها
لم تعلن حتى الان توقيف اي شخص
التصريحات الايرانيه المتضاقطه بشان
التسمم رافقها تشكيك من قبل السلطات في
اسبابها وصل حد وصف حالات التسمم بالتمثيل
او انها جاءت من جماعات متشدده ترفض تعليم
الفتيات
الخبراء يقولون ان هناك فرضيتين حول تسمم
الطالبات اما ان يكون السبب شغب المراهقات
او الخوف الجماعي رغم مرور اكثر من ثلاثه
اشهر على الهجمات الكيماويه لم يتم حتى
الان تحديد المتهم بهذه الظاهره
لكنها طالت حتى اللحظه مئه الطالبات
وعشرات المدارس وسببت حالا من الذعر بين
الاهالي والطالبات
معارضه تركيا ترشيحه كمال كلجدار اوغلو
منافسا لرجب طيب اردوغان في انتخابات
الرئاسه في مايو المقبل وخلال اعلان ترشحه
للرئاسه قال كمال
زعيم زعيم حزب الشعب الجمهوري انه اتفق مع
احزاب المعارضه الاخرى على العوده للنظام
البرلماني واكدت المعارضه التركيه في بيان
انها تعتزم الغاء جميع المجالس السياسيه
الرئاسيه وتعزيز البرلمانيه بشكل كبير في
البلاد في حال فوزها في الانتخابات اضافت
المعارضه تركيا انه سيتم منح كل حزب من
الاحزاب السته وزاره على الاقل في الحكومه
واكد البيان انه سيتم تعينه رئيسي بلديه
اسطنبول وانقره كنواب لرئيس الجمهوريه
عندما يرى رئيس الجمهوريه الوضع مناسبا
بعد اتمام مهامهم بحسب القانون
[موسيقى]
جمهور باشكره هذا
اتضح اخيرا غريم الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان في الانتخابات الرئاسيه القادمه
بعد مخاض عسير اتفقت المعارضه التركيه على
ترشيح زعيمها كمال كلش داروكلو اثر سلسله
اجتماعات ماراثونيه لزعماء تحالف الامه او
ما بات يعرف بالطاوله السداسيه
سنحكم تركيا من خلال التشاور والتوافق
اتفقنا على الانتقال الى النظام البرلماني
المعدل تم التوافق على 11 بندا بهذا
الخصوص اثناء عمليه الانتقال الى النظام
البرلماني سيكون رؤساء الاحزاب الاخرى
نوابا للرئيس الوصول الى هذا الاعلان كلف
المعارضه نزيفا في نقاطها في الشارع بعد
انسحاب زعيمه حزب الخير ميرال اكشنر من
تحالف الطاوله السداسيه احتجاجا على
ترشيحك الجدار اوغلو لمنصب الرئيس حيث دعت
لترشيح رئيس بلديه اسطنبول اكرم اماموجلو
او رئيس بلديه انقره منصوريه واش لكن
اكشنر تراجعت عن موقفها الرافض بعد وساطات
ادت في النهايه الى التوافق على ان يكون
اماموجلو ويا واش نوابا للرئيس في حال
ارتقى الرئيس ذلك مع تحديد صلاح
الوثيقه نصت ايضا على منح كل حزب من
الاحزاب السته حقيبه وزاريه على الاقل اذا
لم تقوم هذه المعارضه اوراقها واستغلال
هذه الفرصه الكبيره خاصه يتحدث عن ظروف
الاقتصاديه عن كارثه زلزال فبتصور اعتقد
سوف يعني تكون هي ورقه
ذهبيه او طبق من ذهب للرئيس اردوغان
للاستمرار في السلطه لفتره او لولايه
جديده اخرى
ومن المقرر ان تجري الانتخابات في الرابع
عشر من مايو القادم على ان يصدر اردوغان
المرسوم الخاصه بالانتخابات يوم الجمعه
المقبل
بعد زلزال هزه اركان المعارضه وانتهى
باعلان كريجدار اوغلو مرشحا مشتركا لتحالف
الطاوله السداسيه هناك من يخشى من هزات
الزلزال الارتداديه على معسكر المعارضه
نتيجه التصدعات التي خلفها انسحاب اكشنر
من التحالف ثم عودتها واللغط والجدل الذي
رافق هذا الانسحاب زيدان زنجلو العربيه
اسطنبول
من جهتي تامر اردوغان احزاب المعارضه
بتحريض الشعب التركي وتكرار وضع العراقيل
امام النمو والتحول المدني على حد قوله
زمان
الاحزاب المعارضه وزعيمها زعيم حزب الشعب
الجمهوري السيد كمال كليتشار اوغلو يقومون
بتحريض الشعب للوقوف ضدنا ووضعوا عراقيل
امام عجله النمو والتحول المدني في الماضي
والان يكررون نفس توجهاتهم
[موسيقى]
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
تجدد المواجهات في بلده حواره بالضفه بين
الفلسطينيين ومستوطنين اسرائيليين
اهلا بكم من جديد قال وزير الخارجيه
الصينيه تشين جانج في مؤتمر صحفي على هامش
الدوره الاولى للمجلس الوطني الرابع عشر
لنواب الشعب الصيني في البرلمان قال ان
بلاده ستدافع بحزم عن سياسه سياده البلاد
وترفض العقوبات الاحاديه محذرا واشنطن من
ان مساله تايوان خط احمر بالنسبه لبكين لا
ينبغي تجاوزه ودعم الاداره الامريكيه
بقياده حمله غربيه لشيطنه الصين عبر
العالم المسؤول الصيني اكد في السياق ذاته
ان بلاده ستواصل اتباع سياسه سياسه خارجيه
مستقله
وداعمه للسلام وستواصل لتنفيذ او تواصل
تنفيذ استراتيجيه الانفتاح متبادله
المنفعه
قالت كوريا الشماليه ان اي تحرك لاسقاط
احد صواريخ تجاربها سيعتبر اعلان حرب
مرجعه التوتر او مرجعه عفوا التوتر
المتزايد في شبه جزيره الكوريه الى
تدريبات العسكريه المشتركه بين الولايات
المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه حذر ايضا كم او
حضرت كم يوجون شقيقه الزعيم كيم جون اون
في بيان من ان
ستعتبر ذلك بمثابه اعلان حرب اذا اتخذت
الولايات المتحده اجراء عسكريا ضد تجارب
الاسلحه الاستراتيجيه التي تجريها كوريا
الشماليه كما المحتل ان كوريا الشماليه
يمكنها اطلاق المزيد من الصواريخ على
المحيط الهادئ
افدى مراسل العربيه باصابه سته فلسطينيين
في بلده حواره جراء تجدد المواجهات بين
الفلسطينيين ومستوطنين اسرائيليين اوضح
مراسل مراسل العربيه ان المستوطنين
الاسرائيليين هجموا منازل ومتاجر في حواره
وعدد السكان واشار مراسل العربيه
عفوا اشار الى مراسل العربيه لان
المستوطنين الاسرائيليين حطموا عددا من
السيارات في حواره خلال مسيره راقصه
احتفالا بما يسمى بعيد المساخر
السياره
[موسيقى]
هجم علي اللي بيضرب
علي في البلطه هان رجعت لدرس مره اخرى
الحكمه واحد بيحكولي يعقوب
الثاني
اظهرت لقطات فيديو تلقي افراد او تلقي
افراد عائله فلسطينيه العلاج الطبي في
احدى المستشفيات منها الطفله بعد تعرضهم
الى اعتداء من قبل مستوطن اسرائيلي قرب
بلده حواره في الضفه الغربيه
[موسيقى]
في منزلهما وسط مدينه الخليل
الذين تمكنوا من فتح الباب وتحرير طفلين
عبد الحفيظيه التفاصيل
[موسيقى]
من نافذه صغيره تصرخ هذه الطفله مستنجده
بامها بعد ان وجدت نفسها حبيسه بيتها مع
اخيها فالجنود داهموا البيت بشكل مفاجئ
واغلقوا ابوابه بالحديد والنار دون تنبيه
او سابق انذار بينما كانت الام خارج
المنزل الضابط الجيش
الاحتلال من البيت ما حكى لها كان هو
الضابط وهو وكميه جنود هو وكميه جنود
نازلين يعني موجودين هون بس ما حكوا لانه
بده يسكروا الدار ولا بدهم يلحموا ولا
بدهم يسووا اشي في اولاد صغار عندك في
البيت عندك بنت عمرها سنتين ونص عندك ولد
عمره 12 سنه موجود هلا في البيت بامكانك
انك تشوفه يعني مبينين على الشبابيك الدار
انا خايف عليهم خايسين يعني يعني ليه كيف
ما رات من هنا
ومش شايفين
بعد دقائق عادت الام والى المنزل لتجد
ابوابه مقفله بشكل كامل وطفليها يصرخان من
النافذه
فاستدعت الجيران وبعض الناشطين الذين هبوا
لتقديم المساعده وخاضوا جدالا طويلا مع
الجنود لاقناعهم بضروره فتح ابواب المنزل
وتحرير الطفلين
تقطن عائله البايض شارع الشهداء وسط مدينه
الخليل وهو من الشوارع المقفله منذ سنوات
طوال ويعيش الاهالي فيه شبه سجن دائم
وتزداد قسوه السجن مع المناسبات والاعياد
التي يخرج فيها المستوطنون للشوارع حيث
قام الجنود باحكام اغلاق بعض البيوت
والمحلات التجاريه بذريعه توفير الامن عبد
الحفيظ جعوان العربيه الاراضي الفلسطينيه
تستمر حاله الاستنفار الامني في العاصمه
الموريتانيه نواكشوط لتعقب اربعه ارهابيين
فارين من السجن بمشاركه وحدات من مختلف
تشكيلات الامن والقوات المسلحه وتتكتم
الجهات الحكوميه على مجريات عمليه تعقب
لدواعي امنيه والارهابيون قتلوا جنديين
اثنين من حرس السجن اثناء عمليه الفرار
هنا سجن نواكشوط المركزي الذي فر منه
اربعه ارهابيين خاطرين البارحه بعدما
قتلوا جنديين من الحرس الوطني وجرحوا
اثنين اخرين الحرس الوطني دفع بتعزيزات
لتامين السجن في الوقت الذي تقوم فيه
دوريات مشتركه ووحدات بحث من الحرس وشرطه
مكافحه الارهاب وترك الوطني بتعقب الجناه
وتقوم بدوريات في مختلف احياء العاصمه
نواكشوط وزاره داخليه تقول ان القبض على
الجناه مساله وقت في ظل استبعاد تمكنهم من
اختراق طوق الامني المفروطي على مدينه
نواكشوط في هذه الاثناء تستمر حاله
الاستغفار الامني التي لن تتوقف على ما
يبدو قبل اعتقال الارهابيين الاربعه
البارين ابراهيم مصطفى العربيه
نواكشوط
وزاره الصحه اليمنيه حمله وطنيه شامله
للتحصين ضد شلل الاطفال في المرافق الصحيه
والفرق الصحيه المتنقله من منزل لاخر
الحمله جاءت بعد رصدي عشرات الاطفال
المصابين بالشلل من النازحين القادمين من
مناطق سيطره الحوثيين محمود الحميدي
وتفاصيل الحمد لله قد صمت شهرين متتابعين
توبه الى الله ان يكون تسببت في موت او
ضرر اي احد من ابناء هذا الشعب العزيز
اعلنوا توبتهم عن ذنب اقترفوه للسماح
باللقاحات سابقا وما هي الا ايام وقد
تسببوا بوفاه عشرات الاطفال
حرموا في مناطق سيطرتهم من التحصين ضد شلل
الاطفال تطورات سريعه لحملات حوثيه مستعره
اعاده اليمن سنوات الى الخلف بعد ان اعلنت
قبل انقلاب الحوثيين خلوها من شلل الاطفال
معطيات دفعت الحكومه الى المسارعه في
تدشين تطعيم واسعه للاطفال في المناطق
المحرره مع رصد عشرات الاصابات بشلل
الاطفال قادمه من مناطق سيطره الحوثيين
الحوثيين ليسوا من اليوم ضد اللقاحات
ولكنهم منهم بداوا حربهم في صعدهم ضد
اللقاحات وضد التطعيم في محافظه صعده
والان اغلب الحالات المصابه ظهرت اول حاله
تقريبا ثاني حاله كانت محافظه سعده من
النازحين في محافظه صعده الى مارب كذلك
اغلب الحالات من المناطق التي تحتلها
الحوثين والتي يمنعون فيها تلقيح وت
طعم
عشرات الفرق الطبيه الثابته والمتنقله
بدات عمليه التطعيم منذ امس الاحد
بالتزامن مع توسع حملات التوعيه الاعلاميه
بضروره حمايه الاطفال وتحصينهم من الشلل
تحرك وجده تفاعلا مجتمعيا واسعا في مارب
وغيرها من المحافظات
وعزز هذا التفاعل الخوف من تفشي حالات
الشلل مع تواتر الاخبار عن ضحاياه في
مناطق سيطره الحوثيين
اتخلص من مرض ان شاء الله
وكان المرض قد انتهى وعندما نحو
تطعيم ضد شلاطف فظهر تم مشكله من جديد
وظهرت حاله وفاه
نجلاء يكون بصحتهم يتمس
وهيكون بصحه جيده تعود الامراض الفيروسيه
والاوبئه التي اعلن اليمن خلوه منها عام
2006 الى الواجهه وتتبخر كل الجهود التي
بذلت على مدى عقود بسبب ممارسات الحوثي
والقناعات المزيفه التي تحاول نشرها
ويكتوي باثارها المدمره اطفال اليمن محمود
الحميدي العربيه مارب
تما هذه النشره الى العناوين
غاره اسرائيليه على مطار حلب الدولي ومصدر
سوري واكيد خروج المطار عن الخدمه
البيت الابيض يقول ان تسمم او تسميم
طالبات في ايران يستدعي بعثه امميه لتقص
الحقائق ويصف الامر بالمخزي
والصين تندد بحمله غربيه لتطويخها وتحضر
واشنطن من تجاوز الخط بشان تايوان
شكرا لكم على حسن المتابعه الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]